[Applause]
uh so I'm just going to want you to be
completely honest with me okay uh so
I've already SE signs that you might be
underneath the or under the influence I
could smell it on you the way that you
were driving and then you're were acting
really nervous okay so have you been
drinking tonight
then I was earlier was like when's the
last time that you
drank cuz your eyes are like glossy
every time you speak it's like you could
smell it real bad on you a coup hours
go I mean if you want drive me back to
my house I you can follow me I will go
home and that's
it where do you live at right here
in okay then why are you going this one
I was going to go back to my ex's house
but I should have done that that was
wrong I admit it it was very
wrong but I live with my friend sah and
I'll go back there you can follow me I
will go back home okay um so what I
could what I want you to do and it's all
up to you uh so it would make me feel a
lot better uh for you driving is if you
would consent to field sobriety
exercises you could pass those I'll let
you go to your ex's house go let you go
to your house friend's house okay I or
go back home
[Music]
yeah huh I don't know like it's been a c
but I don't know if I
can so if you want to follow me back to
where she was I will come home and I'll
give you my te and I'll come in the
morning
okay but I want to go back and she lives
right across from I thought you said
that she lives right across from yeah
she no I thought you said you lived
right I live with her okay you live with
her yes okay I live with her
and I'll go back home and
my it's wrong I should have done it I
swear I should not done it I don't do
this my mom's a CP so I know it's stup
where's your mom a cop at she was influ
PL
okay so I know it's St it's very stupid
me to do this I know it
is
okay it would just make me feel a lot
better um to just to see if you were
even able just to drive back home so
that's why I was seeing if you would do
field sobriety and if you're good we're
good then this is over with it won't
even have to go apologize like I don't
I'm not like this I'm really not no I
get it no that's why I just wanted to
see if you wanted to consent to the
exercises so then I could if you're good
I could just go on my Merry way and it's
I well cuz you just cuz you said earlier
because you don't feel like you can pass
it I just wanted to be sure that you
could drive and then we could go I want
you guys to follow behind me yeah as
long as I go it's literally right there
like at the 7eleven across the street on
Dona we can't let you drive even with us
following you unless we know that you're
good to go yeah cuz I could be held
responsible like say you got into a
crash or it could even be your fault
there someone hit you but me knowing
that you F this I go to jail right or I
someone get me that is what I just
wanted to make sure that you're good to
drive so then if you wanted to go to
your ex's house say you did pass I would
let you go I would go my other way um I
don't even know I just want to be sure
that you're good just to drive yeah so
that's just my main concern and then you
could do whatever you want the rest of
that if you're
good I do I like I gen apologize this is
stupid I know it's so stupid I me to do
this CU drive at all regardless mhm even
if I had a couple drinks earlier it's
stupid right very stupid I know it's
stupid that's my dumbass's fault for
doing this in the first place I should
stay
C and I do not stay
home so I mean I don't know I don't want
to go to gym like my mom is a CP well
she was at like two three years ago she
work with was sah she was there
I just
don't know what the best option is I can
have someone come get me
you well I mean like I can't I can't
tell you um what you want to
do okay we want to thank Morgan and
Morgan for sponsoring this body cam
video I mean I think it's pretty clear
from the body cams that we cover that
it's not always safe out there when
you're hurt it can be confusing it can
be scary you don't really know where to
turn well Morgan and Morgan is actually
the largest injury law firm in America
and in a time when you already have so
much to think about they're going to
make it super easy for you they have
completely modernized the process
because you submit your claim you sign
contracts you upload documents you talk
to your whole legal Team all on your
phone that's it an attorney is going to
review your case in just eight clicks
also they have 4,000 support staff that
can help you too which is just amazing
to think about and in terms of price
well you only pay them if you win
there's no upfront fee so if you're
injured and you want to join the over 3
million people that call them every year
you can submit a claim at www.
forthepeople.com
LC bodycam or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your phone yeah so
um pretty much just uh if you do refuse
I have to go off what you said to
me and um I have to base my observations
from this point so that's why I like to
give you the option to H I don't want to
okay so you would like to do it I just
want to be sure that you're good to go
and
then I would be fine so if you're good
then I would I would feel a lot better
with you
driving so did you want to
participate
well we have to make a
decision we have to figure out what
we're going to do here so you want to
participate in fiety exercises or
no regardless I feel I'm jail so you
guys as
well we didn't say that it's up it's up
to you know I I just got here so I don't
know what you told her so far so it's up
to what the knowledge she has of the
condition right
now
ja nobody wants to go to jail but you
know that's why we have to see if you're
impaired or
not what's that you hard
in the Academy I had to do it all the
time and it's I don't think it's hard at
all it's literally you'll be looking at
a pen it'll be going back and forth and
then you're just going to be walking in
a straight line and you're holding your
foot up approximately 6 in from the
ground and then you're counting 1,1 1,2
it's not that difficult want to give a
shot you want to turn your car off on me
you want to do it down here yeah right
you want she can be put in my car and
I'll take her down there that way I can
position the car to get lights on okay
sounds
good Let's Walk This Way this way yeah
back
okay I guess you can walk her down there
just walk her down there I just need to
get my my Che she
okay go ahead and get your Che
stand over
here
[Applause]
not up here all right so if you want to
just walk down there with her I'll pull
my car down there and uh light it up so
we can see
okay don't even say that girl you don't
even you don't even
know
I I'm sorry like I really didn't I'm
sorry are you going to take me Jo you
might as well just I know like it's hard
my mom it's hard it's only hard if
you're okay so it's only hard if you are
under the influence but if you are if
you're good you would be a you would be
fine like this is all up to
you I don't know if I can pass it like
yes I had a couple drinks but like I
don't know if I can pass it so this
point might as well just take me to
jail and I'll have something up tomorrow
and it's fine like I just I don't know I
know how this is my my mother is a cop I
know how it is I know how the SB test
goes my father is also felon do you want
to get out I don't want you getting hit
that would make me feel so bad if you
got hit I'm sorry but I like I know how
it all is yeah my father is a
felon like I know how it is to do
sobriety test mhm and at this
point I don't want to go to jail in this
outfit like I'd rather like have like a
sweater how old are you 20
20 I know how this is my mom is a former
cop I know I had drinks and it's wrong
so if you want to take me to jail that's
fine I'm completely fine with that I
made my wrong I made my own mistakes so
you don't want to do fbes I just don't
think I can pass it I know how hard it
is what it's your decision I'm leaving
it up to
you I don't know I mean either way if I
fail it I go to jail if I don't take it
I go to jail well we have to base
everything off of what we've seen so
far it's wrong I should have drove like
it's so
wrong it's so fucking wrong I'm sorry so
you want to give it a shot or I don't
know you're take the jel anyways right
not necessarily like like I said if you
do very well on Fu sobriety exercises
that's good good on your behalf you know
but I'm nervous now like I don't I don't
know I don't think I could have pass it
cuz I'm so
nervous I'm sorry I'm so sorry it's so
wrong to drive I'm sorry I really
am so it's your call we can do them
right here and like I said if you do
good it's benefits you if not you know
we go from there
I want to try I do want to try it okay
well let's try it then we don't want to
force you end doing something that you
don't want to do so we'll go ahead and
try it if you if that's what you want to
do also B give you instructions
on oh my apologies okay so the first
exercise is going to be the horizontal
gaze the stagis okay so this is going to
be my stimulus right here
okay okay so you're going to keep your
head still and you're going to follow
the stimulus with your eyes only do not
move your head do you understand the ex
instructions
okay
we're just going to go up
okay so the next is the walkin
turn have tap you have tap no okay
we'll just imagin make an imaginary
straight line okay so just the imaginary
straight line okay where do you want me
to go though if you just would like see
how you're like right there we can use
this one right
here oh yeah
perfect is that easy for you to see or
is that going to be difficult for you I
can see it yeah okay so us walking
straight line yeah yeah so first you're
going to put your left foot on the line
perfect and then put your right foot in
front of it with your right heel
touching your left and you're going to
keep your hands at your
side perfect okay hold on stay right
there so go back into that
position okay yeah make sure so like
this so your other foot your right
foot's up in front your left foot's in
the back make sure your right heel is
touching the left of your foot can you
straighten it out a little bit
okay and then keep both hands at your
side so do not start until I tell you to
do so do you understand the instructions
yes okay so when I tell you to begin
take nine Heel To Toe steps on the line
turn around keeping one foot on the line
and return nine Heel To Toe steps okay
so you're going to
go stay right there stand in front of
you so she can straight okay so the
right foot's up in the front so you're
going to take one two three and so on
till you hit nine and you're going to
keep one your foot plant it on the line
and you're going to take nine Heel To
Toe steps backwards one two three and so
on till you hit nine okay you understand
you know keep your hands to your side
count out loud on every step making sure
your heel touches your toe on every step
okay
okay so once you begin do not stop until
the test is completed
okay do you understand stand the answerr
yes okay you may begin the
exercise
one
4 5 6
two
three
four
five
again no no one's
[Applause]
good okay so the other exercise that
we're going to do is the one leg stand
exercise okay I really B balance
anyways it's okay I do too so just try
your best okay okay really that I swear
so you're going to stand with your heels
together and your arms out to your
side put your toes together there
go do not begin to test until I tell you
to do so do you understand yes okay when
I tell you to I want you to raise one
leg you could do either leg whichever
you feel comfortable your left or your
right approximately 6 Ines off the
ground with your foot pointed out keep
both legs straight and keep your eyes on
the elevated foot
so just like that yeah okay and then
while holding that position I want you
to count out loud 1001 1,2 1003 and so
forth until I tell you to stop okay do
you understand the instructions yes okay
just hang on tight
okay okay
you may begin the exercise 1002 1003
1004 1005 1006 17th 1008 109th 1010th
1100 1200
1400 1500 1600 1700 1800
1900 20,000 20,1 20,2 20,3 20,4 20,5
okay good
stuff okay was that right
close
okay
what's your name s
s okay s you just put your hands behind
your back
okay say you got somebody can come pick
up your
car you have parents or
anything yeah I don't know how to get I
don't know the phone number you have
your
phone we'll let you call or your
boyfriend or so or your ex-boyfriend or
friend I don't know if you want to call
your parents or anything I call them
right Qui yeah yeah of course okay okay
I
started but I didn't finish I didn't
catch the
uh that's fine I like to review my body
camera before I do any of that I was a
little late
on remembering to do that it's okay I
thank you
okay is your
phone drivers are
crazy apologize
about wrong I know
it's your phone going to be in the car
yeah
um it's probably in my driver
SE do you want to
it here do you want to I'll go get it
for you out of your car you want the
windows rolled up and everything yeah
okay and then I'll let you make a phone
call when you're back
there let me like St my house so I can
change I don't want to go to jail on
this
who you your friend lives by 7-Eleven do
you think she could come and bring you
clothes real fast here I don't think
she's
there um do they let them change real
fast they chilles want to go in that um
we just talk about like I don't want to
go we can't go buy your house and pick
up you have anything in your car
sweatshirt I don't think so I don't know
they'll put um a blanket over you there
m so we
can't if you had something with you you
got to go back to
RP hello see if yeah see if one of your
friends could come to the yeah I'm going
to
jail I'm going to
jailand her and read her or um ask her
the questions she I swear to God I'm
going to right
now out of
the
[Applause]
all right I'll see you when you get
here want do this no cuz the Jail's
going to lose it you want to keep it
here or keep it in your car or what are
is the the Jail's going to lose it no
they won't they they vacuum SE it to a
piece of cardboard and it has your name
on it okay I'll take it then I got to
put it in the front that's fine and hit
your thing because you can't take that
with you and then do you got anything on
your person that you know about like on
me yeah yeah okay is it okay if you
stand right over there of course
okay yeah yeah I got you some clothes
there's clothes in there yeah you're
wear a dra yes okay just so you know if
I don't find it and it does go to the
jail it's a third Dee charge okay yes I
know I know about all the charges
fortunately that's why I'm in this F
situation I just don't want to go to
jail and
fish you know how those girls are in
there they're girl try to get me I'm
pretty I'm too crazy though and there's
nothing in your underwear no
okay
don't you get there yeah when we get to
the PD I'll let you change into this
okay
okay you can leave this in my car so I
can
get okay ready
yes I don't
smoke it's very cold it's cold in there
huh it's cold in here it's very cold
okay I'll change it for
you um so read her Miranda rice when we
get there yeah then ask her questions
over again where she coming from how
much she have drink all that stuff okay
um who's going to do the BTO St is okay
perfect he's already there
perfect
excess my arm